- [David] Hello, Readers.
Today we shall take the
field in rhetorical combat,
also known as argument.
Argument is when an author
wants to convince you
of their position.
"This is my position; you
should share this position,
and here is why."
Argument does not sneak,
it does not come in through the back.
It is supported by reasons,
evidence, examples.
Not just pure opinion, not
just cherry-picked stories:
data, fact, observable reality.
There is a place for
pure subjective opinion,
and it is the realm of the
movie and the restaurant review.
"I did not like this movie
because I didn't laugh at its jokes."
"I did not enjoy the hamburger I got
because I found it too dry for my liking."
This is not what we're
talking about today.
Obviously, argument is rooted in opinion
and subjective personal preferences,
but those opinions need to
be backed up with evidence.
Let's compare arguments for
and against a tax on soda.
Now, this writer argues that
sugar contributes to obesity,
and therefore, people should
be prevented from buying soda,
which is full of sugar
on the grounds that it is bad
for them, let's take a look.
The soda tax could alter
many people's behavior,
causing them to stop buying sugary drinks.
Some foods are necessities
like milk, eggs, and bread.
People will buy them even
if the prices increase.
Sugary drinks aren't necessary.
If the price goes up, people
will buy fewer sugary drinks
and they won't be consuming as much sugar,
therefore, the obesity rate will go down.
Whereas this author counters
that people have a right
to make what they see
as unhealthy decisions.
Soda and other sugary
drinks have been targeted
because they lack nutrition
and are basically just liquid sugar.
Most people would agree that
proper nutrition is important
for maintaining a healthy lifestyle.
However, do legislators have
the right or responsibility
to regulate people's sugar intake
in order to improve their health?
I say, no.
All right, let's evaluate these claims.
For the first argument
in favor of the soda tax,
how do we know this is true?
What evidence does this author give
that this tax will
alter people's behavior?
What evidence does this author give
that sugary drinks aren't seen
to be as essential as milk?
After all, not everyone
can or does drink milk.
In the piece, the evidence
that the author gives us
is this table, which shows how much sugar
is in soda per serving,
but it doesn't use evidence
to connect sugar consumption
to unhealthy outcomes.
All this says is, soda has a lot of sugar.
I wanna see evidence, I wanna see studies.
How do we know this tax
would change behavior?
Good readers think through
the impacts of an argument.
If this tax went into effect,
what would the consequences be?
Are there faults in the author's logic?
It might stop some
people from buying soda,
but in an unfair way.
Here's how I'm processing
this as a reader.
If you take a bottle of soda
that previously costs, say $2,
and the tax makes it $10,
that will make it more
difficult to purchase.
But to a millionaire, the
difference between $2 and $10
is basically nothing.
Whereas to a poor or middle class person,
that $8 difference adds up pretty quickly.
I see this as a possible
unintended consequence
of this proposal, that it
hits poor people harder
than rich people.
As readers, it's not just our
responsibility to interpret
what the author is saying, we
also have to ask ourselves,
what are they not saying?
In the second argument,
the author is arguing
that it isn't the
government's responsibility
to determine how much
sugar people consume,
and therefore taxes on sugary
drinks are unnecessary.
So now I'm asking, whose
responsibility is it
to determine how much sugar is in a drink?
Why is sugar so inexpensive to begin with?
Do legislators have a
responsibility there?
Now we know it's not
legal to bottle rat poison
and sell it as tea, but
whose responsibility is that?
What isn't this author saying,
and how does not saying
it serve their argument?
They're not saying what the
government could or should do,
only what it shouldn't do.
And this is why I want you to be skeptical
whenever you read anyone's
argument about anything.
You need to figure out what
the terms of the debate are.
What does the argument assume as a given?
What's a problem worth fixing?
What are the trade offs
that the writer thinks are acceptable?
So when you encounter an argument in text,
look for the claims, and then
look to see if those claims
are backed up with
data-supported reasoning.
Is the author using evidence and logic?
Do they anticipate
objections to their arguments
and push back on or
incorporate those critiques?
Above all else, I want
you to remain skeptical.
Everyone's selling something, even me.
It's just the thing I'm trying to sell you
is the fundamental idea
that you can learn anything.
You've got this, Readers. David out.